l'audace de l'humanisme je suis un
indigène d'ici j'ai grandi sur les bord
de ce lac
j'en ai appris les us et coutumes une
certaine lenteur et en même temps voyait
en moi un besoin énorme de connaître une
chose et son contraire de tout remettre
en question de chercher la vérité
j'ai beaucoup lu j'ai beaucoup étudié et
puis c'est besoin d'aller au delà c'est
probablement ce que vous appelez
l'innovation avec sur la photo si vous
le voyez ce soir besoin de voyage pour
aller vérifier ce que j'avais appris je
commence par après l'université quitter
notre suisse romande dans un vieux bus
vv avec quelques copains et on met le
cap sur katmandou quatre mois de route
de poussière à travers les déserts
d'afghanistan et autres pour débarquer
là bas comme professeur d'université
j'enseignais la politique internationale
mais en même temps j'ai eu la chance de
vivre dans une famille hindoue pendant
six mois j'ai dû apprendre à manger avec
la main droite dont il était gaucher
et puis connaître les rimpoché les
prêtres tibétains et même j'ai eu à
rapatrier quelques hippies qui m'a
permis de connaître
l'anti monde de celui dans lequel
j'avais grandi alors vous imaginez bien
que revenir sur les bords de notre lac
après
une telle expérience c'est difficile il
faut se réadapter
mais surtout ce que j'ai appris c'est
qu'il ne je n'ai jamais eu peur du
changement que ce soit un changement
géographique que ce soit un changement
de fonction
chaque fois il ya un apprentissage et
chaque fois c'est enrichissant
parce que derrière tous les défis
derrière la misère derrière l'injustice
qu'on croise parfois il y a le regard
d'un enfant il y a une main tendue il y
a toujours l'humain et c'est à ce voyage
au pays de l'humanisme que j'aimerais
vous convier bien sûre face aux
incertitudes
on commence par se méfier
on ne croit pas à la globalisation ça
fait peur c'est la faute à l'immigration
l'autre est toujours suspect on n'est
plus et nous avec tous ces immigrés bien
lorsqu'on est seul au monde
les tracas c'est céder tout petits
véhicules qui montrent à travers les
vignes du lavaux alors évidemment on
peut faire un championnat du monde il ya
que deux trois villages voisins qui en
font la globalisation on la craint
pourtant je peux en témoigner de par ma
vie le monde est magnifique le monde est
d'une beauté d'une sérénité et malgré
toutes les tragédies qu'on peut
connaître en contrepoint de cela le
monde est toujours quelque chose qui
mérite d'être découvert la condition
ces doses allait oser aller au devant
des autres alors ici avec une classe
moyenne
quelqu'un dans une maroquinerie en
amérique latine ou alors la haute
société ou bien la basse
peu importe ce qui est important fai
cette espèce de jeu de tout tamponneuses
permanence où on est avec les autres en
échange et on n'apprend pas par soi même
on apprend de ce que les autres nous
envoie comme regard il faut oser nous
devons nous laisser surprendre
j'aime aller au devant de l'inconnu ici
dans le yosemite
ou bien ces contrats font entre un vieux
réverbères et des gratte ciel dans mon
histoire
comme je vous le disais d'abord il ya eu
ce sel était cet électrochoc de
katmandou et puis j'ai eu la chance de
faire une étape au cicr
je me suis retrouvé au liban dans ce
monde confrontation entre chrétiens et
musulmans où j'ai vu la mort de près
dans les camps de réfugiés plus tard
quand j'ai été envoyé en rhodésie
zimbabwe j'ai même vu un prêtre rôti sur
le grill avec du plomb verser dans la
bouche et dans les oreilles parce qu'il
avait parlé un des deux camps en conflit
s'était vengé on voit des choses
épouvantables
c'est vrai et puis je suis entré chez
nestlé en afrique en amérique latine
j'ai eu l'occasion de participer aux
grandes privatisations des entreprises
de l'europe de l'est qui était en train
de basculer vers notre monde économique
en aidant par exemple les chemins les a
dans sa campagne puis nouveau changement
j'entre dans le monde de la logistique
chez les hollandais avec tnt puis les
français
avec la poste française et dpd puis les
allemands avec dhl finalement à la tête
du conseil d'administration de la poste
suisse
tout ça pour quand on rentre au pays
créer ma propre société on est très
proches et des questions
environnementales et des questions
d'entrepreneuriat c'est de cette
confrontation permanente entre les
cultures et entre les activités
professionnelles divers que jaillit
l'étincelle la créativité et chaque fois
le goût j'allais presque dire la
boulimie d'en faire encore plus et c'est
toujours ce sourire au coin d'un marché
aux endroits les plus insolites qui vont
nous apporter cette part d'humain qui va
résoudre une partie des problèmes
auxquels on est confrontés en permanence
faire aujourd'hui les problèmes sont de
plus en plus globaux est un problème
global correspond bien sûr une solution
globale
si vous regardez la situation de
l'énergie les besoins énergétiques du
monde sont croissants et si vous
regardez ici en rouge
l'asie a demandé aux chinois de
continuer d'aller à bicyclette parce que
le père était à bicyclette non donc tu
auras des besoins croissants auxquels il
faut faire face d'une façon ou d'une
autre
l'immigration sur cette carte vous voyez
déjà la carte du monde
corrigés en fonction de la population
vous avez une aide qui est déjà très
gonflé si je voulais mettait en 2100
vous verriez quelque chose encore plus
dramatique
vous voyez ici tout en haut de la courbe
l'asie et puis l'extraordinaire montée
de l'afrique avec 3 milliard et demi de
population et puis tout en bas
insignifiant l'europe les états unis le
japon le monde développé
vous avez le problème de l'eau ici on
est au dessus de l'iran vous avez déjà
aujourd'hui à travers le monde un
déficit de 20 % d'eau potable de qualité
acceptable et ça sera probablement un
des grands défis de la deuxième moitié
de ce siècle
alors face à toutes ces difficultés
heureusement il ya des solutions ça
passe par une prise de conscience ça
passe aussi par la technologie
par exemple dans le domaine de
l'environnement les cleantech vont
apporter une grande partie de la
solution
probablement aussi par l'économie
circulaire on va réutiliser une partie
de ce qu'on avait
parce que par exemple étaient rares on
n'arrive pas en retrouver en suffisance
nouvel an chinois
au début de cette année je m'amusais de
voir le désir des chinois est de
posséder leur suisse mais au delà ça ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ce sont
les échanges qui créent la richesse
ça ne sert à rien de s'isoler il
tellement normal qu'à travers les
échanges mondiaux ont créé davantage et
davantage de richesse donc je ne suis
pas du tout personnellement opposé à la
globalisation la même chose vaut pour
nous en suisse évitons de nous retirer
sur notre pâturages la prospérité de
notre pays vient justement de son
ouverture au monde culturellement fait
du rassemblement de la rencontre entre
ces différents types de civilisation
vous aviez le tibet ici abou dhabi ici
par hasard on est en amérique latine
mais on pourrait être à new york et
l'inde
c'est de cette confrontation que vont
être des étincelles de créativité et les
nouvelles solutions
alors permettez moi maintenant de vous
raconter au travers de ce que j'ai vécu
quelques exemples où l'humanisme
l'emportent en dépit des circonstances
premier exemple nous sommes ici en
colombie
et vous voyez arriver un paysan qui
porte un sac de café ça s'est passé il
ya deux semaines tout à fait par hasard
j'entre dans la coopérative des
caféiculteurs et que ce que je vois par
hasard la liste de prix et regarder
nespresso 10 fois le prix d'un autre
type de café alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que si nous en
occident on est capable avec des efforts
marketing de créer un produit premium
malgré ce que certains disent on arrive
quand même à payer 10 fois le producteur
c'est peut-être passé mais c'est quand
même une réalité
autre exemple il se trouve que je vais
partie d'une formation aux états unis
qui s'appelle europe
on aide les jeunes américains
essentiellement ceux des classes moins
favorisés à être ce qu'on appelle
financial litscher on essaye de les
éduquer à utiliser leur argent de façon
intéressante à ne pas toujours abusé de
la carte de crédit et à être
responsables même dans un pays très
développé ce genre de choses sont
nécessaires
abu dhabi ici nous avons avec une des
sociétés dans lesquelles je suis
impliqué lancer un produit qui permet à
la fois de nettoyer et de désinfecter
avec de l'eau c'est de l'eau électro
lisez et vous n'avez pratiquement pas de
substances chimiques dont qu'il existe
des solutions parfois permettent de
faire face aux problèmes de l'écologie
très sain et dans un pays qui manque
d'eau extrêmement efficace l'un
l'inde est un pays à la fois de castres
parfois de misère ici une fille qui
cherche des poux dans les cheveux de
l'autre mais en même temps c'est le pays
de la haute technologie et je travaille
un peu avec des incubateurs à bangalore
vous avez pour six places dans
l'incubateur 2000 à piquants qui presque
tous sont des porteurs de projets
intéressants un potentiel extraordinaire
où l'un ou singapour j'ai travaillé
l'année dernière ce rallye 25 fois donc
ça veut dire à peu près tous les quinze
jours j'ai pris l'avion pour aller
là-bas où on a pour le compte du
gouvernement travailler sur un énorme
projet où il s'agissait entre autres par
exemple de créer un métro marchandises
souterrain l'idée étant de d'éviter trop
de camions et mais surtout dans une
première phase de créer un district
industriel avec 200 usines sur un
kilomètre carré
donc on crée des tours et toute la
logistique intégré un seul des solutions
center pour 200 usines
toutes ces solutions qui sont des
solutions intelligentes de l'avenir sont
là à notre disposition ce plan là
souvent l'asie est des leçons à nous
donner
alors quelles sont les conditions la
première c'est d'oser le courage de
l'innovation
si vous êtes en asie du sud est vous
êtes face à des traditions millénaires
comme dans les temples d angkor ou à des
cultures qui sont restés statiques
pendant très longtemps ici sur les bords
du mais quand ou alors
l'industrialisation mal comprise
l'électrification dans une des rues de
bangkok où à la fin de vraies solutions
planifiez et moderne la deuxième
condition c'est le respect mutuel c'est
la tolérance c'est la non confronte
assure je ne crois personnellement pas
qu'on va résoudre les problèmes en
interdisant notamment dans le domaine
religieux
l'interdiction du voile
l'interdiction de souci non la solution
elle est davantage dans le fait
d'autoriser mais d'être intransigeant
sur le fait que chacun doit respecter la
culture de l'autre c'est essentiel est
de nouveau il y aura une cross
fertilization une mutualisation qui est
enrichissante pour tous et finalement
c'est la question de la confiance
nous avons une planète nous en sommes
tous dépositaire et il faut que nous
aidions nous avons l'envi d'aider cette
planète qui est unique et où nous vivons
tous à se développer
le monde qu'on aille le découvrir qu'on
soit face à quelque chose de grandiose
qu'on soit dans quelque chose de plus
humbles le monde est un monde de passion
partagée vous l'aurez compris je suis
moi même un passionné
je crois que c'est à travers cette
passion se ambitions de témoins de la
passion qu'on arrive à trouver
l'étincelle de l'humanisme dans toutes
les circonstances et des solutions
harmonieuse merci